welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid the topic of discussion today
astronomy you mean like when Mars is in
retrograde and I'm having a life crisis
no no that's astrology what other
planets are doing has nothing to do with
your life in astronomy we study things
that happen mostly outside the Earth's
atmosphere which frankly is a lot of
stuff what I want to focus on in this
video is the stuff that everyone should
know the stuff that should be basic
knowledge to all human beings this
mainly consists of what things are
called
it's kind of a pet peeve of mine when
people use these words incorrectly it
makes me want to explode I'm gonna show
you these things in order from smallest
to largest
first asteroids comets meteoroids
meteors and meteorites I put all these
together because they're all basically
the same thing it's the leftover junk
from when the solar system was made
they're all composed almost entirely of
iron nickel and cobalt and they usually
have very irregular shapes what we
usually call asteroids range anywhere
from the size of the semi-truck to the
size of Mount Everest comments are just
asteroids with a layer of ice on the
outside so nothing special
as for meteoroids meteors and meteorites
astronomers are just getting ridiculous
at this point meteoroids are just
asteroids smaller than trucks meteors
are just what we call meteoroids as
they're entering Earth's atmosphere and
meteorites are just meteors if they
happen to touch the ground there's no
reason to have all these names they're
all just asteroids a planet on the other
hand is a little more difficult to
define in fact the International
Astronomical Union or IAU took a crack
at it back in 2006 but when you have
that many people from that many
different places trying to agree on
something
no one leaves happy their decision
resulted in the following definition a
planet is an object orbiting the Sun
that is large enough to be both
spherical and to have cleared out other
objects of comparable size from its
orbit the short version they decided our
solar system had eight planets Mercury
Venus Earth Mars Jupiter Saturn Uranus
and Neptune bye-bye Pluto and good
riddance you never really belonged
anyway bring on the hate comments at the
center of our solar system you'll find
the Sun which is one of a great many
stars
wait the Sun is a star yep and a rather
small one at that it isn't called a
yellow dwarf for nothing in fact
compared to some other stars you can
barely see it be grateful though if it
wasn't small we wouldn't be here
stars are really big balls of plasma or
perhaps a miasma of incandescent plasma
the Sun isn't on fire it is fire well
sort of and its temperature of about
10,000 degrees Fahrenheit determines its
color yellowish white the Sun might be
small for a star but it's still huge in
this picture of the Sun this blue dot
over here shows the size of the earth
for comparison you can fit a little over
a hundred earths across its diameter
huge okay so the biggest mix-up I see
people have is between star systems and
galaxies a star system is a small
collection of asteroids planets and
stars our solar system is an example of
this containing eight planets a bunch of
asteroids in a single star having a
single star isn't very common though
combinations of two or three stars
appear the most and in the last twenty
years or so we've discovered that tons
of stars have orbiting planets planets
are turning out to be extremely common
are you excited I'm excited galaxies on
the other hand are huge collections of
star systems what's that I lost you okay
so here's our star system the solar
system wait for it wait for it wait for
it here's the galaxies these things are
really big our galaxy the Milky Way is
about a hundred thousand light years
across that means it takes like a
hundred thousand years to cross from one
side to the other you can even have
smaller galaxies orbiting larger ones
we have two major orbiters called the
large and small Magellanic Clouds
unfortunately when an average person
says galaxies they're probably talking
about a star system even Nintendo mess
this up calling one of their games mario
galaxy but then I guess Mario star
system wouldn't have sounded as cool
anyway stop saying it wrong so were you
happy with the decision to demote Pluto
let us know in the comments with some
details hate comments appear and until
next time remember it's okay to be a
little crazy
you